WE'LL BRING IT TO YOU WHEN WE
GET IT.
>> John: ERIC, THANK YOU.
GILLIAN.
>> Gillian: IN GEORGIA, BRIAN
KEMP IS FACING A REMATCH AGAINST
STACEY ABRAMS.
THEY FACED OFF LAST NIGHT, THE
FINAL DEBATE BEFORE ELECTION
DAY.
JONATHAN IS ON THE CAMPAIGN
CONTROL AT A POLLING CITY
OUTSIDE ATLANTA.
TELL US ABOUT THE VERY HEATED
MOMENT IN THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT
OVER POLICE REFORM.
IT GOT A LOT OF TRACTION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> CERTAINLY DID, GILLIAN.
AT ONE POINT GOVERNOR KEMP
ATTACKED ABRAMS SAYING SHE WAS
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
SHE VEHEMENTLY DENIED IT SAYING
IT WAS NOT THE CASE, AND THEN
THEY ARGUED OVER LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENDORSEMENTS THAT GOVERNOR KEMP
RECEIVED.
>> MEN AND WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
BE WITH THEM AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THE ENDORSEMENT OF 107
SHERIFFS AROUND THE STATE.
>> I'M NOT A MEMBER OF THE GOOD
OLD BOYS CLUB.
SO NO, I DON'T HAVE 107 SHERIFFS
WHO WANT TO TAKE BLACK PEOPLE
OFF THE STREETS, ABLE TO GO
WITHOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> ABRAMS QUICKLY ADDED SHE DOES
NOT BELIEVE EVERY SHERIFF FEELS
THAT WAY, AND THAT SHE WOULD
DEFEND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WHILE ALSO HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
HER COMMENTS LIKELY RALLIED HER
PROGRESSIVE BASE BUT ALSO GAVE
FUEL TO REPUBLICANS EVEN OUTSIDE
THE RACE FOR GOVERNOR.
TODAY REPUBLICAN SENATE
CANDIDATE HERSCHEL WALKER
WEIGHED IN ON ABRAMS' COMMENTS.
>> SHE'S COMING UP WITH STUFF
LIKE THAT TRYING TO SEPARATE
PEOPLE, GET OUT OF THE COLOR
THING AND GET INTO THE LOVE
THING.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK YOU NEED TO
GET INTO, GET INTO THE LOVE
THING.
GOD LOVES US ALL.
>> ABRAMS AND KEMP ALSO SPARRED
OVER ABORTION.
ABRAMS SAID A LAW THAT KEMP
RECENTLY SIGNED, GEORGIA'S
HEARTBEAT LAW WOULD POTENTIALLY
SUBJECT WOMEN EXPERIENCING
MISCARRIAGES TO UNDUE
QUESTIONING AND SCRUTINY.
KEMP SAID THAT WAS NOT THE CASE,
THAT THE LAW WOULD POTENTIALLY
CAUSE DOCTORS PERFORMING ILLEGAL
ABORTIONS BUT NOT THEIR FEMALE
PATIENTS.
>> John: BRING IN OUR PANEL,
MERCEDE
MERCEDES, AND JUAN.
CLEAR POLITICS, GENERIC BALLOT
GRAPH WHICH SHOWED -- THERE IT
IS, SORRY, I COULD ONLY SEE PART
ON ONE MONITOR, ISN'T THAT
INTERESTING.
YOU CAN SEE HOW REPUBLICANS
MONTHS AGO WERE OUT IN FRONT AND
THEN IT CLOSES IN AND NOW
REPUBLICANS ARE BACK OUT IN
FRONT AGAIN.
MERCEDES, THEY HAVE A LEAD THAT
IS PROBABLY AS BIG AS IT EVER
WAS AND A BIG TURN AROUND FROM
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE?
>> WELL, I GOT TO TELL YOU, I'VE
BEEN ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, I
JUST CAME BACK FROM MICHIGAN AND
ARIZONA, AND WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING TO THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, JOHN, I THINK THE MAIN
FOCUS IS, IT IS ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
I MEAN, BACK TO THE FACT THAT
FOOD PRICES ARE HIGH, GAS PRICES
ARE HIGH, PEOPLE ARE FEELING THE
PINCH, THEY ARE STRUGGLING AND
NOT HAPPY WITH HOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE HANDLED THE ISSUE.
THEY FIND THAT EVEN THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT NOT
REALLY TRANSLATING INTO REDUCING
THE INFLATION WHICH IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
SO I THINK THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
JUST STRATEGICALLY FROM A
MESSAGING STANDPOINT DID NOT
CAPTURE WITH THE SENTIMENT OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE.
FOCUSED TOO MUCH ON ABORTION,
TRIED TO NOT HONE IN ON SAYING
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO HELP
OUT THE ECONOMY, AND HAS NOT
RESONATED WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> JUAN, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING AT THAT, AND NEED SOME
HELP ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
DO WE GO TO JOE BIDEN, NO, LET
HIM STAY IN DELAWARE FOR THE
WEEKEND.
HIS WIFE GOES ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, AND BARACK OBAMA, STILL A
ROCK STAR IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BUT IN HIS FIRST MIDTERM
ELECTION DID PRESIDE OVER 63
SEAT SHELACKING.
IS HE THE RIGHT PERSON TO BE ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL?
>> MAYBE THE BIGGEST STAR ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, JOHN, AND NOT
ONLY BARACK OBAMA OUT THERE, I
THINK YOU SEE MRS. BIDEN, I
THINK YOU SEE BERNIE SANDERS,
REALLY WHAT YOU SEE IS THEY ARE
TRYING TO GENERATE TURNOUT
CRITICAL TO THE RESULT OF THE
MIDTERMS.
YOU WANT TO GET YOUR PEOPLE TO
THE POLL, AND SO FAR THE TURNOUT
HAS BEEN RECORD BREAKING, AND SO
THAT'S GOOD NEWS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND GOOD NEWS FOR THE
STRATEGY SO FAR.
I THINK MERCEDES IS RIGHT, BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO THE CASE PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT OTHER
ISSUES, IT'S NOT THAT THEY ARE
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT ABORTION OR
THREATS TO DEMOCRACY, AND ALL OF
THAT IS IN THE BALANCE AND THE
QUESTION IS WHAT GETS THEM TO
SHOW UP AND VOTE, AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU SEE COMING FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> John: WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SENATE RACES, FOUR ARE GOING
TO DECIDE THE BALANCE OF POWER
IN THE SENATE, THEY ARE TIGHT,
POTENTIAL, MERCEDES, OF
DEMOCRATS LOSING THE HOUSE,
LOSING THE SENATE, AND THEN JOE
BIDEN SPENDS THE WEEKEND IN
DELAWARE?
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> LOOK, I THINK THIS WHEN YOU
HAVE A VERY UNPOPULAR PRESIDENT,
UNPOPULAR VICE PRESIDENT, THEY
ARE SIDELINING KAMALA HARRIS AS
WELL, IT JUST SHOWS THAT I DON'T
THINK THE DEMOCRATS FULLY HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR OWN LEADERS.
SO I THINK IT'S SMART TO BRING
OUT FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
MICHELLE OBAMA FOR THAT MATTER.
BUT THE REALITY IS, WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING ARE THE INDEPENDENTS
SWINGING OVER TO THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE.
EVEN WHEN YOU HAVE TULSI
CAMPAIGNING IN MICHIGAN ON
SATURDAY, BASICALLY NOT HAPPY
WITH WHERE THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
IS, SHE LEAVES THE PARTY,
BECOMING A POPULAR FIGURE AMONG
INDEPENDENTS AND REPUBLICANS,
IT'S A TELLING STORY.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT CRIME, YOU
TALK ABOUT BORDER SECURITY, AND
THAT'S WHERE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
REALLY FAILING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SO WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE
ALTERNATIVE.
THEY WANT STRONG BORDERS, THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE SAFE
COMMUNITIES AND STREETS AND
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING UNDER
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
>> John: JUAN, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HEARD ERIC'S RECORD BUT
GOVERNOR HOCHUL SAID LISTEN,
CRIME IS NOT THAT BAD.
IS THAT THE MESSAGE VOTERS WANT
TO HEAR, OR CRIME IS BAD AND WE
WILL DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO COUNTER
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO MAKE SORT OF
HYPERBOLIC CLAIMS OUT OF
CONTROL, AND HOCHUL SAID SOME
HORRIFIC ACCIDENTS AND INCIDENTS
AND THE MAN SHOVED ON THE SUBWAY
IN NEW YORK CITY.
THAT'S SCARY TO ME, TO YOU, TO
MERCEDES, EVERYONE.
BUT THE REALITY IS WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH A PANDEMIC, AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE STATISTICS, CRIME IS
ACTUALLY WORSE IN SOME OF THESE
STATES RUN BY REPUBLICANS AS
OPPOSED TO DEMOCRATS BUT
REPUBLICAN MESSAGING IS OFF THE
CHARTS AND THAT'S WHY YOU GET
THE DEMOCRATS CAUGHT BACK ON
THEIR HEELS SAYING WAIT A
SECOND, LET'S LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS, LOOK AT THE REALITY.
SOME CASES HOMICIDE IS UP AND
VIOLENT CRIME OVERALL DOWN.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING.
IN TERMS OF PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
HOCHUL, I THINK THEY ARE BOTH
NOW FOCUSING ON GUN CONTROL AND
SAYING WHICH PARTY IS THE PARTY
THAT REFUSES TO HOLD PEOPLE WITH
GUNS ACCOUNTABLE, AND WE SEE SO
MUCH OF THIS IN TERMS OF THE
HOMICIDE RATE GOING UP.
LOOK AT WHO IS REALLY
RESPONSIBLE.
BUT AGAIN, DEMOCRATS ARE ON
THEIR HEELS AFTER THE REPUBLICAN
MESSAGING ON CRIME.
>> Sandra: FINISH IT OFF, WHAT
WAS YOUR THOUGHT, MERCEDES?
>> REAL QUICK, JUAN, WHICH IS
THE PARTY THAT HAS SUPPORTED
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS, AND THE CITIES ARE
RUN MOSTLY BY DEMOCRATS WHERE
THE CRIME IS HAPPENING.
THE DEFUND THE POLICE MESSAGE
HAS HURT THE DEMOCRATS.
AS YOU WERE SAYING, THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GAIN THEIR
FOOTING FROM AN OFFENSIVE
STRATEGY, YOU ARE SEEING SUCH
CLOSE NUMBERS IN STATES LIKE NEW
YORK WHERE LEE ZELDIN MAY WIN
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE.
>> I WANTED TO SAY, IF YOU LOOK
NUMBERS, IT'S IN REPUBLICAN
STATES WITH REPUBLICAN POLICIES
WHERE CRIME IS THE WORST AND YET
YOU NEVER HEAR THAT, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONES WHO
HAVE BEEN PUSHING THE CRIME
MESSAGE.
AND LET ME STATE CLEARLY, IT'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE.
YOU CAN'T GET AWAY FROM IT.
>> John: